we've thrown the names Mark Ferguson
hawgotsby around on this channel quite a
lot recently but who even are they
welcome to Sidetrack your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so Mark focus and his professional
partner Hawke oxby have been in a
working relationship for a very long
time helping to write movies such as
children of men Iron Man and Cowboys and
Aliens but sci-fi fans will know them
best as the guys that bought the expanse
to our screens whilst the expanse is
originally created by James S.A Corey
which by the way is a pen name between a
collaborative Duo known as Daniel
Abraham and Ty Frank it was Mark and
Hawk who developed the show for the
Sci-Fi Network they were both also
executive producers for the show and
have been actively developing the show
ever since even after it was picked up
by Amazon back in 2019 after the Sci-Fi
Network canceled it in 2018 but what
does all of this mean for Stargate well
if you're a regular side tracker you'll
have no doubt heard by now that Amazon
were soliciting pictures for a brand new
Stargate series one Euro that were
approached from Mark and Hawk from
penguin inner Parker which is their
production company so Janet before I
interrupted you with that question we
were talking about MGM
Amazon soliciting pitches and Mark
Fergus and as far as you know right
right in the rumors that some of the
more successful genre shows that have
been on Amazon like the boys and the
expanse yeah those writers have pitched
or have been invited to pitch something
Stargate related right and it's
young people who had done it prior to
the buy and then Amazon because of its
sci-fi Silo had sent out the call for
lots of sci-fi fantasy and still are
it's still a silo they're worldly work
as well as procedural and some others
that they've decided to focus on so
one of the things that was done was that
they would say with certain production
companies that they had either already
worked with or were really excited about
like Mark Fergus and Hawk his partner
and said hey we loved what you've done
what would you like to do we'd love to
get and they said my understanding is
they said sorry now I've I had heard
this prior to when uh Sidetrack had
talked about it a recent video on this
channel announced that it's very likely
that they have now won the race and uh
in the process of drawing up contracts
we might expect to see an announcement
officially from Amazon as early as
January
but tell me guys in the comments what do
you think about this news are you
satisfied that Stargate will be in good
hands with these two whatever happens
Stargate is closer than has ever been to
being back on our screens which is the
biggest development update we've had in
over six months we're all aware that
Brad Wright's script didn't make the cut
for whatever the reason may be Amazon
has decided to press on with someone
else this doesn't mean however that Brad
Wright won't be involved at all and we
could potentially see a working
relationship between penguin and a
Parker and Brad Wright himself I mean
Brad Wright Joseph malozi and Robert C
Cooper they all worked on the original
Stargate television series alongside
countless talented writers directors and
producers could it be the if Stargate
returns Mark and Hawk draw on the
talents of the previous teams who
appease fans and make the greatest
version of Stargate they can
for me this is fantastic news I'm a huge
fan of the expanse I love everything
they've done with that television
program and I'm a huge fan of Stargate
now the the very idea that Mark and Hawk
would have been well when this was first
announced back in August when that news
broke I was super excited and I made it
very clear that I'm very excited about
this as well on all the live streams
that we do Etc
now it looks like it's coming into
fruition I am so excited that Stargate
could potentially be returning I am so
excited so happy so I can't even explain
how I feel inside the only real question
is is it going to be a reboot or is it
going to be a continuation of what we've
seen before and I'm still in two minds
as to what which one of those is going
to be the best option with the
continuation they're gonna have to tread
very lightly as not to mess up the
cannon that's come before it but with a
reboot they can come in with some fresh
ideas they can retell some of the same
stories but perhaps with a Different
Twist and that's exciting whatever the
case may be whether it's a reboot
whether it's a continuation or whether
it's a hybrid of the two
I'm gonna watch it because I love
Stargate and I love the expanse which
was developed by these two and if it's
even half as good as what the expanse is
I honestly believe that the new Stargate
franchise could be huge but what do you
think let me know in the comment section
down below I'm very eager to hear what
you guys have to say about this and I
will be looking at the comment section
very very closely all that's left to do
is say thank you for watching and if you
are new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe press the Bell notifications
so you don't miss a single video and
whilst you're down there consider
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
hit the join button down below thank you
so much for watching and I will see you
next week
[Music]